concern over anticipated shortages of
food and other supplies is driving
people to supermarkets and big-box
stores in many places shoppers are
finding empty shelves long lines and
limits on purchases but experts say do
not worry mark Strassmann is inside a
local Atlanta business where the shelves
are stocked and the lines are short mark
I'm coming to your shop why is it like
that there well here's the story Anthony
and good morning this is a can of Park
Market it's an in town independent
grocer if you want wine if you want
peanuts if you want wasabi green peas
they got it but if you want bread you're
out of luck same thing note no hand
sanitizer no toilet paper
and if you want the dairy section which
is over there this is all they have left
but here's the deal some of these little
guy grocers actually have more in the
shelves than the big guys shelves picked
to the bone at a Walmart in Washington
State over-the-counter medicines
vanishing from a target in Virginia long
lines and bear shells at this Whole
Foods in New York City panic mode
there's no time for getting better it's
a scene being repeated at brand name
stores all over the country Sunday even
the president weighed in the stores are
stocking up at a level that's beyond
Christmas time there's no need for
anybody in the country to hoard
essential food supplies there is no
chance that they will not be able to
fill their dog bakeries but the food
industry association
he says the industry is trying to adjust
to all the shortages there could be
periodic shortages and there might be
times where consumers might not be able
to get it for a couple days but supply
is flowing machines are running and the
product will make its way back to the
shelf Baker says now is not the time to
panic but to think about others before
you buy more than you absolutely need
buy the items that you believe you need
to have in order to do that but also
remember your neighbors and your
families and your friends and your
co-workers are also trying to do the
same thing and if you purchase too much
of that item that hand sanitizer that
household cleaning solution then you
actually take that away from somebody
else and you actually put them at risk
for this virus so this market is
expecting a supply truck later today but
they have no idea what's on it is hit or
miss so what they don't have on the
shelves today they may still not have on
the shelves tomorrow
Gale I know tomorrow my last mark woody
said was very helpful
remember your neighbors toilet paper we
all need it we all use it please don't
buy more than you really need what are
you doing about that mark Strassmann
everybody's out of toilet paper
I'm leaving it to my wife who's a much
better person than I am and she's only
buying what this family needs Thank You
mrs. trosman thank you mark good to see
you